president ibrahim raisi held a news
conference to highlight his government's
achievements but also defended iran's
nuclear program
from the beginning the zionist regime
didn't want us to have access to nuclear
science but it's become part of our
country you can't take it from us these
zionists did all they could to stop us
to kill our scientists but we didn't
stop none of their actions will be able
to stop us this is an absolute right of
iran
he came to office more than a year ago
promising to fight corruption and
restore iranians trust in their
government
ibrahim raici was the former head of
iran's judiciary who won the
presidential election securing nearly 63
percent of the votes in the lowest
turnout since the 1979 revolution only
49 percent of the public voted reyesi
campaigned to reduce unemployment
inflation and address a growing housing
problem
but it's been a challenging first year
in office with iran's economy continuing
its decline
inflation is around 40 percent the
unofficial unemployment rate hovers
around 30 to 35 percent with nearly 60
percent of the population now living in
poverty
economic
stagnation and
corruption remains a key challenge for
the reiss administration
and
nobody's expecting this to be fixed or
resolved within a short period of time
one year is not sufficient
to see that happening
he needs more time president raising
isn't just fighting to save the economy
but attacks like this also highlight the
difficulties facing iran's security
apparatus on may 22nd in south tehran
two armed men on a motorcycle opened
fire on a vehicle driven by general
hassan sayat hodai from the quotes force
of the revolutionary guards the general
died on the spot iranian officials
blamed israel
three days later another suspicious
incident in the town of parchin near the
capital at one of the heavily fortified
military compounds
the incident killed the defense ministry
engineer essan karplege
there's been no official word about the
cause of his death
the other issue dominating raises first
year in office has been the diplomatic
effort to restore the landmark 2015
nuclear agreement
these talks are aimed at bringing the
united states and iran back to full
compliance the deal saw iran limit its
nuclear program in exchange for
sanctions relief
a deal israel has strongly criticized
and said it will not prevent it from
doing what it needs to do to stop iran
from developing a nuclear weapon
and those talks have now reached the
stage where a draft agreement has been
presented according to the european
union foreign policy chief joseph
burrell that will require serious
political will from officials in tehran
and washington the two sides are now
exchanging notes on that text and what
happens next will not only have
ramifications for millions of iranians
but will also define ibrahim raising's
first term in office
dorsojabari al-jazeera tehran